change why she's gotta be it under lives
change our sky [ __ ] organizing
Mazal might change the world
so every Wednesday I love to chairs to
someplace special on campus it's
actually a pretty normal place to most
people walk by it's a little grassy spot
in between an admin building and a
library it's usually sunny with some
shade provided by a couple trees and
there's a sidewalk in front but in
between classes teams with students so I
said this chairs facing each other
I sit in one chair the other chair is
empty and I said I wait it's a sign of
my feet so I sit and I wait for anybody
who wants to to talk now when I'm doing
this I keep this this mantra in my mind
to listen seek to understand first don't
judge and above all don't give advice so
when I sit there people walk by some of
them smile
some of them laugh a little bit some
people look at me like I'm crazy but
some people stop and talk and those
people have changed my life people like
the lady whose set in that empty seat
and she leaned in and quietly told me
her story on the verge of tears and
she'd been promoted at work but she was
still very unhappy my initial advice
there would have been suck it up you
just got promoted whining but what I
didn't realize is that for somebody for
tenure this promotion had been too
little too late and she still felt very
underappreciated by her organization
furthermore she was the only one who had
been promoted and so now she was
alienated from her former colleagues and
friends people like the homeless man who
approached in a ratty sweatshirt and
jeans and he was a drug addict and he
wanted desperately to get clean I want
to tell him hey just get your act
together go to a no worries what I
didn't realize is that he and him never
had a choice in the matter
he grew up in a household where both his
parents were meth addicts and he had
done his first line of coke when he was
only 13 our people like the Haitian man
in New York City who's out of work and
feeling alone I wanted to tell him
there's jobs out there you need to work
harder go get it
and if you need some support turn to
your family again what I didn't realize
he was actually highly educated
overqualified for most menial jobs that
you can get furthermore he had no one to
turn to because his family back in Haiti
had disowned him because he was gay and
he had AIDS the only person he could
turn to was his lover back in Haiti but
he couldn't go back there because he
need to stay in the United States to
receive the medical care it's only
available here so he was truly alone so
when I sit and listen to these stories
what I know that all I can do is listen
I've been want to do something like give
free advice for a long time ever since a
friend of mine decided to take his own
life afterwards I kept thinking what if
I'd been more present more willing to
listen more available with the outcome
have been any different and my friend
might still be alive I was struck by the
fact that in big cities like New York
and San Francisco you can bump into
literally hundreds of people in a day
with current technology you can reach on
you can communicate with thousands of
people in an instant and yet there's
still millions of people who
alone and depressed and disconnected so
for me given free advice is a small step
in the right direction with so many ways
to communicate we need to find ways to
communicate with more empathy to cut
through the noise and to say something
meaningful and to be truly present for
others so in doing free advice I have
actually learned a couple things the
first one is obviously you actually
don't give advice most people know the
right answer they just need somebody to
walk along that path with them to listen
to them to reassure them I've learned
that most people who are mean or angry
aren't bad people they're just having a
bad day I've learned that my initial
judgments of people are usually wrong
especially when those judgments are
harsh I've learned to ask more questions
and to be a little more understanding
and I've learned to write more letters
most importantly I've learned that
everyone has someone in their lives who
needs somebody to hear them to listen to
them and it's up to us to make ourselves
available and open for those people now
sometimes when I'm sitting out giving
free advice and I'm leaning in intently
listening to somebody story trying to
understand trying to ask the right
questions trying to be there for this
person I glanced up and I see that a
line is formed of people waiting to talk
when I think about this I realized that
if she's a guy in an empty seat and a
sign you might sit down it may seem like
a novelty you want to talk see maybe see
how crazy this person is what they what
are they selling but when there's a line
it says something completely different
it says that there's a huge need for
something like this that there's so many
people out there that don't feel like
they have somebody in their own lives
that they can turn to to talk then
instead they sit and they wait in the
line to talk to a stranger
so I'd encourage you to give free advice
in your own lives challenge you to do so
you don't need a sign and you don't need
to talk to strangers you can do some
very simple things write a letter to
somebody you care about not necessarily
say thank you or congratulations just
make sure you say what you really need
to say invite a friend out to coffee but
make sure there's no agenda to discuss
but keep the mantra in mind
listen seek to understand first don't
judge don't give advice and be truly
present for others thank you